[Applause]
it's not just the dance but the face
that you make while you're dancing
you are i i don't you like the guy the
single guy at the airport bar
or at the wedding reception who just
isn't drunk enough yet to actually get
up and dance
but he bites his lower lip yeah it's the
fighting of the lower lip
but hey laugh away you got a number one
bestseller you
thank you thank you
first obviously who do you credit the
success
of the book you yes is that what you
want me to say
well you could say yeah you could say me
i could say you all right i credit
you greg i credited you because you have
how many best sellers
i think i have well i have five new york
times best sellers okay
nine books total but i wasn't really
trying with those other books okay
all right so i'll get there but i don't
think i ever got a number one hey i got
lucky because
uh mark levin came out the next week and
crushed me
yes so with timing was everything it is
in fact you if
people don't know this but the book
publishers that's all they do is they
try to find slots
right and they go you don't want to come
out when this book comes out because
you're not eve no one's going to buy
your book they're right
they tried to find the slowest slot of
the summer
to release my book and they nailed it so
great job guys
it's true great job
what uh and uh what was your favorite
part of writing the book
my favorite part were the mom texts
because that was already written
so that was the least amount of work did
the publishing
that is the company part and then at the
end when you see it saying like you went
from one to
30 pages i went from 200 pages to 250
pages
yes but mom's not getting any royalties
do you remember i remember i
had an interview well i had to i wanted
to interview bill o'reilly for a red eye
and i got a copy of his book and that's
what we were doing he wouldn't even come
to my set
so i had to go do it in his set and when
i got the book i opened up in the last
like
90 pages out of 180 was an interview
with
he did with barack obama a transcript it
was a transcript i have a lot of
transcripts in how i saved the world
it's like i'm like going wait a minute i
i seem to remember this from the
o'reilly factor
but then i did that with my monologues
yeah so my daughters who are nine and a
half were very impressed not that i
wrote a book that it was over
300 pages yeah they were like the first
question they asked dad i said i wrote a
book they said
how many pages and i said 300 they were
like you wrote 300 pages
to them that's a lot but to any any
first-time author or any people who
doesn't
that's the that's the obstacle it's not
the first page
it's when you look at the book and you
go like how do i i don't think it's
possible to do that because that's what
i thought i always thought like there's
no way you can put
you can put that thing together it's
impossible but what happens is
an outline does everything right and
also
bigger font and double spacing that'll
take you a long way
i got a great idea for your next book
what you're inspired so much by bill
o'reilly
killing gutville that book writes itself
yes it does i'm actually killing myself
that's what it would be it would be all
my behaviors and daily habits
i should write a book about you yeah it
wouldn't sell
yes it would it'll just be all
transcripts well you know what
you know what your next book is it's how
i save the world part two part two
because
because there are you obviously didn't
succeed
you didn't succeed i didn't succeed all
right we gotta move on uh it's called
how i saved the world you can get it
anywhere you probably already bought it
but bye too
thank you you know mother's day and
father's day are coming up next year
i stole several copies yes you did
that's why you need bubba
ah baba hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else